vous avez ça alors fini donc une hyper
view vérité c'est pas n'importe quel est
donc l'interview je sais que le principe
du fair use donc on est déjà à 2 3 4 5
contre vous et deuxièmement comme celle
d'hyper view vérité vous allez dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
vous êtes d'accord très bien serge
khalfon lumière spéciale s'il vous plaît
tous contre moi
voilà pas contre tout contre alors
allons-y
tout le monde parle de vous parce que
j'ai fait un bond en avant dans les
sondages c'est officiel j'ai pris quatre
points au baromètre du figaro magazine
et des gens en novembre il faut les
rendre ce qu'ils n'aiment pas ça au fil
des ans le groupe 98 sondage louis
harris alors vous est la troisième
personnalité de droite la plus populaire
après chirac et ce gars et il faut le
dire quand même
elle ouvrira ici votre modestie doit en
souffrir vous êtes devant madela
monsieur madelin derrière douce
vous n'êtes pas je dis ça pour vous
assurer que vos copains vous êtes devant
sarko oui sarko ville derrière d'oust
vous êtes devant beyrouth ça c'est
encore pire oui berrou derrière bon
alors et vous avez dit comme je ne serai
pas comme kouchner fait plaisir d'abord
d'être devant tous ces va voir si ça
parce qu'il a dit je ne saurais pas
comme kouchner et langues
une bulle dans les sondages donc je veux
dire que non seulement vous est la
troisième personnalité préférée de la
droite mais en plus de ça vous comptez
continuer à monter non c'est pas monter
mais quand vous faites de la télévision
quand vous avez des thèmes aussi
importants que celui des retraites moi
j'ai un bouquin aussi que j'ai en parlé
rassurez-vous bon 90 à votre retraite
pour sauver ma retraite je le montre
avec amertume changer ma retraite par
philippe douste-blazy chez plon north
gagne avec le prince à washington bon
allez demander pardon là mais quelques
uns l'ont fait
quant au fait de la politique on le fait
à la fois par ambition personnelle dont
le fait aussi pour des idées assez forte
et j'ai eu la chance un effet depuis une
dizaine d'années que ce soit au niveau
de la santé que ce soit au niveau de la
culture d'être bombes sur des sujets qui
sont en plus ni de droite ni de gauche
qui sont des sujets un peu universelle
je crois que c'est un peu pour ça que je
suis vous êtes monté comme ça dans
l'opinion et dans les sandales et pour
ça bon alors au début faut dire la
vérité vous n'aviez pas un crédit
fantastique avez votre ami seguin qui
disait vous ouais tout ce que blazy
c'est un danseur mondain
pas sympa y'avait fillon marque ans et
plus est ma fille on sait plus tellement
qui sait j'ai dit aux petits danse ça
doit quelques jolis
fillon il disait mais fillon à
connaissez fillon oui si on disait t'as
qu'à te disais il m'est arrivé la pire
chose de ma vie on m'a pris pour
douste-blazy donc tout le monde vous
brocardé un petit peu philippe contraire
cette somme là c'est qu'ils savent être
arrivé un truc bien on m'a pris pour
fillon oui et alors ce que les gens
n'ont pas noté c'est qu'en fait c'est
allé très vite si elle rend 89,7 maire
de lourdes en 93 d'autres ministres et
en 98 le président du groupe udf à
l'assemblée l'enrichissement est loin de
vous maintenant les figurants la d1 vous
faites l'hyper view et cardiff
c'est quoi pourquoi vous dites ça je lis
et un peu sommet d'une carrière souvent
aussi bien joué c'est désagréable pour
lui merci
non il est sympa bon je pose plus de
questions que j'avais prévu on va parler
de botnie j'ai vraiment bien
page 68 vous dites ça s'amplifie bon
normes et quand même c'est vrai vous
êtes vous êtes imposés par exemple à la
présidence enfin du groupe udf à
l'assemblée sérieusement je dis on
espère que vous êtes imposé parce que
vers où nous allons mais entre beyrouth
soutenez robien et vous bayrou et boules
c'est vous qui avez été l'une assez
parce que tout simplement on faisait un
parti politique qui s'appelle nouvelle
udf françois bayrou devenu président du
parti est moche devenu président du
groupe
je suppose que je dirai tout à fait
normalement il ya eu une élection il ya
une campagne j'ai battu gilles de robien
campagne électorale non l'armée lui lui
il aurait préféré
il aurait préféré par donc ça soit ça
soit robien verrous il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de campagne électorale très dur
contre moi franchement de la france
franchement je vous le dis franchement
vous appelle à vous l'aimez great bear
ou parce que des bus berrou il était
sympa avec vous il vous a aidé comme ça
tous les rêves du même coin là bas dans
sud ouest il vise à aider maintenant
quelques kilomètres l'un de l'autre
oui et à manger pris votre envol tout
seul en laissant un peu comme ça au bout
nous ont dit on dit douste-blazy c'est
un peu le maigri de beyrouth d'abord
sais pas je l'invité l'autre jour dans
le cadre de sa campagne européenne
lou il a dit que nous étions des amis de
100 ans
parce que mon grand-père a soigné sa
grand-tante il ajouté elle est morte
jeunes
est né donc en 1953 vous êtes médecin
enfin professeur fils de médecin et dire
quand michel crépeau a eu son attaque à
l'assemblée vous êtes allé lui faire un
massage cardiaque avec kouchner et le
choeur est reparti mais ce pauvre michel
crépeau est mort d'ailleurs parce que
nous n'avions pas de cannes une
ventilation au moment de sa réanimation
alors qu'elle ait des pompiers des
médecins de l'assemblée nationale il y
avait manqué au kenya une passion c'est
pour ça qu'il est mort les jours après
l'hôpital cochin et on aurait pu le
récupérer
parce qu'elle avait fait le coeur est
reparti bon alors dans votre adolescence
vous pratiquer le golf et la musique
classique les voitures détient fou de
bagnols lui ai même fait le rallye de
monte carlo à 77 ouais et vous et ziti
faisait longtemps hésité entre la
carrière dans la médecine et la voiture
en 1976 j'avais deux solutions ou être
puis d'autres usines
ouais on va la refaire une médecine je
sais c'est bon alors qu'un jour on peut
piloter des petites voitures
donc outre l'irak
quand vous vous lancer en politique à
lourdes pour être maire de lourdes donc
votre vous avez effectivement quelqu'un
qui est là depuis des années qui
s'appelle françois abadie qu'un vieux
radical socialiste et vous avez un seul
concurrent
si vous voyez venir qui s'appelle joël
jarroux rpr miracle et ça me fait
rigoler ça insensible vous avez une
chance dans la vie que je trouve insensé
doit 6,9 pour michel crépeau leur fiche
est bien pratique nommée sais rien mais
je n'ai rien gagné
vous avez l'impression de donner
l'impression que je gagne ce qu une case
sur quelqu'un meurt c'est très
désagréable
alors excusez moi de vous le dire bien
je me sens pas très bien vous avez
impôts joël germain trop tard pour
partir il est pas trop tard
je l ai jamais sérieusement j'ai déjà
route c'est vrai je peux dire unis et
rhys davies et qu'ils soient décédés
mais avouez que c'est elle que c'est un
peu comme j'ai envoyé karl zéro j'adore
bâclé pas je vous l'assuré excusez moi
est ce que je dis plus rien je tiens à
dire ici que je n'étais pas à côté de
jeunes j'ai roulé ce qu'a fait ça
sinon il y aurait fait un massage
cardiaque l'aimerai toujours là vous ne
sauriez pas merveilleux sur la valeur ce
qui voulait dire dans 54% des voix j'en
avais en question ce serait est-ce que
vous pratiquez le vaudou
alors le 9 février 1999 il n'ya pas
longtemps il ya eu un miracle alors le
66e miral qu'un dénommé jean pierre bel
il y avait la sclérose en plaques à geri
vous y croyez vous qu être médecin c'est
ça la vraie question est ce que vous qui
êtes médecin et catholiques est ce que
en tant que médecin c'est difficile de
croire qu'il suffit d'aller à la grotte
de lourdes pour guérir la sclérose en
plaques et en tant que catholique en
même temps vous devez y croire alors si
les deux derniers cas parce que l'église
fait tout pour ne pas dire que les
miracles
oui ce legging clashs ça eh ben oui
c'est vrai il faut dix ans pour être sûr
que c'est une guérison inexpliquée
oui les deux derniers c'est une avant
dernière cette jeune fille de 16 ans
tumeurs osseuses stade iv près terminal
avec une métastases hépatiques donc du
foie
ça veut dire à peu près deux mois deux
mois et demi maximum je dirais
vie en sicile milieu très pauvre le
village se regroupent pour payer le
voyage à lourdes elle va à londres trois
mois après il n'y a plus rien ni sur les
radios ni sur les scanners ni sur l'irm
ni sur les plaques histologique donc je
veux dire et la sclérose en plaques la
même chose pareille multiples a senti
qu'il avait une chaleur en lui il s'est
levé il a marché
évidemment comme scientifique ce quelque
chose qui me sidère et je n'ai pas faim
il n'y a pas d'explication à cela ce que
je vais vous dire c'est qu'il y a ce que
l'on appelle un bureau des constatations
qui tous les ans pour des milliers de
personnes constate le dossier médical
est aussi médical fait le tour du monde
ouais il y a plus de médecins qui ne
sont pas catholiques que de médecins
catholiques dans le bureau il est vrai
que ces deux derniers cas sont
totalement inexpliquée on n'a jamais vu
alors à l'époque il devait y avoir
certainement des cas un peu limite
maintenant qu'on a les scanner l'irm
histologie série 10 ans attendez-vous à
l'air sceptique
peut être que sceptique c'est ce que
c'est la première action qu'on doit
avoir mon scepticisme ça veut pas dire
que j'y crois que je crois pas je prends
pas parties sont d'accord même si c'est
vrai 2 mais je vois les explications
c'est très peu la fois mais les trucs
autour ça maintenant mais ça on parle
pas demain autour n'en parle pas de suri
des mois qu'on est sûr que c'est un
miracle mais tout le monde parce que non
mais le général est le vrai miracle de
lourdes
en fait vous avez raison c'est pas ces
logiciels de vrais miracles do with me
fallait faire un miracle de lourdes
ce n'est pas je me dis on est bien
sérieux depuis longtemps le fruit de
lourdes ce n'est pas qu'il y ait des
guérisons inexpliquées c'est qu'il y ait
5 millions six cent mille personnes qui
viennent tous les autres filles 2 cas
sur un autre miracle à lourdes phillips
et c'est un jour vous balader donc je
rue de la grotte et vous entrez dans un
magasin qui s'appelle le magasin belge
il ya un type avec un opinel qui lui
donne un coup de couteau
bon et miracle là aussi poumon touché
vous survivez est ce que vous y voyez
sérieusement est-ce que vous y voyez
quelque chose de
surnaturel ou est-ce que non ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que j'ai eu très
très peur pour lui
pendant douze ans de ma vie j'ai été
responsable des soins intensifs de
cardiologie donc j'ai reçu beaucoup
beaucoup de malades qui avaient reçu des
coups de couteau et que si la porte est
touché c'est 35 secondes devant vous
mais c'est l'artère pulmonaire ces 15
minutes quoi donc au bout de 15 minutes
16 minutes j'étais très content et très
très rassuré sur le poumon ce n'est pas
grave
la cm de taille sur le poumon mais bon
j'étais très très bien soigné à
l'hôpital où ils m'ont sauvé la vie
parce qu'en même temps il y avait alors
des couteaux à éviter la honte quoi
oui et c'est passé juste à côté de
l'oeuvre donc c'est assez dire que c'est
quasi miraculeux et vous avez essayé de
jouer au tennis contre monica seles
est ce que vous aviez déjà pas pris un
coup de tournevis par le même mais
monsieur bricolage et le civil étaient
même site il était ressorti à l'essai
est ce que ça nous a pas rendu un petit
peu plus méfiant sur le laxisme de
l'univers carcéral qu'un si ça nous a
mis un coup de tournevis au juste le
temps de mettre un coup au final ça
c'est un énorme problème aujourd'hui la
justice française qui ne s'intéressent
pas la dangerosité des gens mais
uniquement à la responsabilité
et comme lee considéré comme un
psychiatre hic il n'est pas considéré
comme responsable a pas de son lait ne
va pas en prison il va vite à
psychiatrique
et puis à moment donné le psychiatre
peut trouver qu'il va mieux et le laisse
ressortir et donc c'est toute la
question que le grossiste qui se pose
aujourd'hui l'assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs mais le garde des sceaux pour
savoir si dans les cas de récidive pour
les criminels est ce qu'il ne faut pas
non plus qui y est certes les
psychiatres qui donnent leur avis ouais
mais aussi quand même les jumelles et ce
type là et les effets toujours en
liberté là aujourd'hui et en hôpital
psychiatrique
ouais mais dès qu'il va sortir il va
venir vous voir l'alerté en version
versions dites moi vous savez qu'il est
albanais quand même avec tout le mal que
vous aimez pour les uns c'est pas tout
et vous même vous êtes serbe
il doit le froid
isabelle this is a basic channel adnane
cif qui est il et albanais non mais
c'est quand même incroyable nous regarde
je voudrais pas que même donné trois bis
est négatif sur lui mais nombre de
tentes et toi d'abord parce que d'abord
parce que très sérieusement je ne lui en
veux pas dans la mesure où les malades
c'est un malade psychiatrique deuxième
quand on sait que quand on dit qu'il est
malade c'est le temps qu'il fait bon
comme étant payé par jack lang il faut
que vous avez fait ce qu'a fait le pape
le pape jean paul ii il est allé voir
alliés axa dans sa prison et lue quoi
oui bien sûr il ya des grandes îles a
fait aussi au moment des faits parce
qu'ils avaient intérêt à le faire
c'était quel intérêt il avait pas ce que
parce que c'est le papy les
représentants de tous les catholiques
icéo d'avoir un geste de miséricorde du
pape alors que nous on continuera rd40
voulez je vous l'avais rencontrée je
suis rencontrent deux fois cette
occasion la wii le dos de traces il aime
bien le moment hésité en fait chaque
fois qu on lui pose la question est ce
que vous connaissez de ce buzz y répond
ne se mouille pas cet homme j'ai pas du
tout qui sait les gares et donc
je me suis souvent posé la question et
je crois que je vais le faire oui je
pense que j'irai le voir très bien alors
quand vous étiez ministre de la santé
vous êtes battus contre le sida
logique 1 quand vous étiez ministre de
la culture s'est battu contre le front
national
logique mais vous savez bien que je vous
poserai la question il ya que jack lang
que vous n'êtes pas arriver éliminé
parce que le sida se soigne plus le
front national comprendre ce qu'était la
gueule pouvez pas comparer à l'e3 mais
ceci étant je vous réponds jack lang
jack lang a eu une chance je dirais et
du talent mais une chance c'est qu'il
reste ministre de la culture disant oui
comme andré malraux et je reconnais
qu'en dix ans on peut quand même marqué
aussi un ministère tu viendrais pense
qu'on va regarder un petit extrait des
guignols seul vous détendra